every December neighbors all over the
country have their yearly Christmas like
pissing contest outdo each other which
is just when you want around a bunch of
power strips and there are photos of
these retina burning holiday hell holes
all over the web's I'm gonna show you
some bad Christmas lights and for 200
any points just answer a few questions
about them very simple no big deal just
a few questions are you nervous you seem
nervous why are you so nervous you
shouldn't be saying anything anyway
let's get started but you do seem a
little nervous all right let's start
with the lights to kind of remind me of
something but I can't quite just Reggie
what is going on here if if you build it
it will come yeah
from field of creams uh James Adomian
clearly the happiest ending of the year
yes bargain he's celebrating that
special time of year when your dick gets
infected oh